support for me marriage is not that
important anymore I want to have a
partner and I want to be with somebody I
I would like to get married and get
engaged and you know build this
life with someone okay but that's not
something that that's my like sole
purpose in life so if you were 40 yeah
didn't ever got married no kids I'm just
hypothetical no kids but you had a good
career I would like would that be enough
to satisfy you I would I always wanted
to be a mother so I I want to be a mom
before I'm 40. yeah because of like all
the of course no that's why I post it
that way so I would definitely want to
be a mother and I would be disappointed
if I'm not a motherboard okay how about
you Ali if you never got married and
you're still at work on your career
let's say you're an influencer but
you're still single would that be a
disappointment there would absolutely be
a disappointment that's not how I want
my life going down at all and you know
there's something to be said about if
you don't have babies your DNA doesn't
go on and you're really just kind of
like well you know life is pointless I
think kids give women purpose and I
think that we lie to women when we tell
them that that's not true that your job
is going to fulfill you it's not the
same thing as watching a tiny human grow
look at look up at you and learn learn
but you know I've noticed sometimes that
women will say that they want kids but
they won't say that they want a specific
man's kids and I think that's an
important distinction
how do you mean what's the distinction
there so okay
um for people that follow me content
they're pretty familiar that I had a
miscarriage earlier this year I ended up
going to Facebook support groups because
I don't know who else to talk to about
that stuff I ended up going there and I
found two very different schools of
thought there are women that were
married and in relationships where they
wanted to have children but it didn't
work out but then there were other women
that were grieving but they're just
looking for a guy to get the job done
like they're literally hunting for men
to impregnate them they haven't given a
thought well I mean what's the cost
going to be to the child so I think like
if we're going to talk about women
wanting to have children and that's like
in the plans then like you know uh I
know sperm is cheap but we still need it
we still need it so you know what what's
up with the guy where's he at how are we
gonna get him okay and then Pearl if
you're 40
YouTube blown up million subscribers you
killed it but no husband no kids would
that be satisfying none of it would
matter like like to me if you have
nothing to pass on and like even if who
cares if you're rich if you're alone
you can have all the money in the world
but if you don't have like a family to
go home to that's sad I I um I did this
thing where I interviewed um Executives
like top Executives in Milwaukee and
there was a couple that I interviewed
that like had no family no kids and you
could just see how sad they were and I
like who cares if you have all the
success if you have no one to share it
with yeah that makes me think I have a
couple friends down here in South
Florida they're both
I would say very successful estate
planners right so high profile lawyers
estate planners and they were both
you're familiar with the concept of
dinks dual income no kids oh yes thanks
and they're both you know crushing six
figures easily
um and they were not gonna have kids and
then
lo and behold I think after like 10
years of marriage they decided to have
kids now they're on their second kid
because they realized holy [__] I don't
know what I was thinking here okay by
the way is this something this
discussion that we're having right now
is this something that women sit around
and discuss no this is not just just
okay why is this not a like guys we will
shoot yo what up bro see that girl yeah
here's what I'm thinking yeah like why
don't women have these types of
discussion why does it take sauce cast
on value tape and subscribe right now to
bring this type of conversation to the
Forefront why don't ladies have this
discussion ladies don't have walkovers
this discussion right here they both
nodded their head and said no they don't
talk about this do you talk about this
kind of stuff with your friends stuff
like wanting to Career woman getting
married uh being of course being a
housewife rather than an independent
woman so you're saying you do have these
conversations we don't really talk about
all of them I try to surround myself
with people who are very ambitious and
career driven so I can learn from them
and like we can all build each other up
but we never talk about like oh if I
don't get married if I don't do this
like we're all talking about just like
so building a career one of the you
ready to take some calls in a second
Natalia
um one sec but one of the terms that I
constantly hear because I'm asking
all sorts of people
um what specifically women on traits or
qualities they find attractive in a man
and a term that constantly gets put out
there is ambition he's ambitious oh my
God he hasn't made it yet but he's
ambition he's got some Drive he's got
ambition that's attractive it's
attractive quality
I don't know if men are like Oh that
girl right there she's ambitious I love
how ambitious she is they're not okay so
guys I don't care about that your
boyfriend he loves the fact that you're
ambitious yeah but you said boyfriend is
it meaning that's not her husband how do
you mean I would be curious right so if
Coco and this guy right they end up
working on the long term if he's a
masculine man I'd be I would wonder if
you'd be in the kitchen making some
breakfast we both make breakfast I made
it today he made it yesterday
no I don't I don't need photo proof I'm
just saying I would be curious to see if
that femininity switch would flip for
you
so is there a switch that women have to
basically tap into is that what you're
saying well I think women should
consider femininity from the beginning
but the West is just really awful at it
that I think Eastern culture has
femininity figured out way more but I
think some women they're ambitious boss
babe that's all I care about but then
they meet a strong masculine man yeah
and they're like okay you know what like
maybe I'll work part-time you know how
okay how do you want your steak medium
rare what kind of side do you want I've
seen it happen in real time women are
like I would never serve a man and then
they have the hot plate in their hands I
cook for my man yeah I have no shame in
admitting that I mean in Europe we learn
how to cook like every woman pretty much
knows how to cook but that's not
something that like I'm not gonna not
work because like I need to make a meal
like making a meal is
something very normal in my life there's
a difference between making a meal and
making a home yeah
well I mean there's yeah a maid can like
clean for you a cook can cook for you
but only a wife can make a home
so that's like family traditions culture
and like what are you passing on to your
children
gotcha so that's again your dream life
is to be you know happy wife happy life
but your dream like forget about a
million subscribers you want to make a
house a home yeah I just want a lot of
kids like I think I'm pretty cool so I
feel like if there's like five of me
running around it'd be even cooler you
ready for what kind of soup by the way
guys in the Super Chat we're gonna be
answering your questions today uh we're
we're these women as as I just want to
thank you guys for being here and
everyone has a different uh opinion
respect respect everyone's getting along
great but I do want to answer some of
the questions from
um valutainers out there in the audience
to tell you got something that you want
to ask um so there's one question from
Nate uh throughman he said why would a
man that values marriage want to marry
you that's a question who me just in
general why okay so why would a man who
values marriage want to marry you okay
go down the line you're a Coco you go
first why would a man who values
marriage would want to marry me yes
I'm not really sure if I understand that
question so a guy who wants to get
married yeah why would he want to marry
you oh so basically you're asking me
what it brings to the table or is that
yeah is that what it is sure and we'll
go down the line this you're not being
singled out okay no no I know
um well it's a very strange question
honestly for me but I would want to
marry somebody that I see building I if
I'm with my boyfriend now and I see
marrying him one day if we get to that
point because he is a good partner he
helps me do certain things and I help
him and I I would it's easier to live
life with somebody